to some breaking news this hour and a
mother has been convicted of
manslaughter and her partner found
guilty of murder of her nine-year-old
son Alfie Steele died after being
repeatedly beaten and held in a cold
bath as part of what was described as a
Sinister regime of punishment inflicted
on him he had 50 injuries at the time of
his death including bruises all over his
body and signs that he had been deprived
of oxygen and a warning this report
we're about to play contains details
some people may find distressing Skies
Becky Johnson has been following the
case
she was trying to explain away his
injuries
her lies had begun when she called 999
ambulance services the patient breathing
no he's not
he fell asleep in the bath
the truth is nine-year-old Alfie Steele
had been repeatedly beaten then held
under a cold bath as part of an ongoing
regime of punishment he had more than 50
injuries and showed signs he'd been
deprived of oxygen
as his mother pretended she didn't know
where her fiance was hello
[Music]
hello Dirk Howell was running away from
the house the police caught him as he
tried to get on a train he hands up for
me so
so at the moment
she under arrest
Alfie had suffered over a year of abuse
there were times he was locked outside
the house in droitwich in Worcestershire
a neighbor recorded his desperate
screams to be let in
[Music]
neighbors were so concerned they
repeatedly called 999 this was April
2020. I'm hearing some really worrying
noises from that door I've heard what
sound like a child in distress and this
a month later
I support them before yes
this lab we believe is called Alfred
then most significantly this in August
emergency hello it sounds like my
neighbors and doing something bad to
their kid in the bath like they're
really hurting them that was six months
before Alfie died the warnings to police
were clear and Social Services were
involved too they'd put in place a
protection plan that meant Dirk Howell
wasn't allowed to stay overnight a rule
the couple repeatedly flouted in the
year before Alfie's death social workers
had considered removing him from his
mother but they didn't this is yet
another case where a child known to the
authorities to be at risk has died
leaving serious questions about what
more should have been done to protect
him
an independent child safeguarding review
is underway but any lessons will come
too late for Alfie Becky Johnson Sky
News droitwich